east à paris réponse cinglante du
gouvernement c'est charles pasqua qui a
mis les choses au point cet après midi
au palais bourbon
le ministre de l'intérieur répondait à
une question de jean françois deniau
relatives aux critiques de l'étranger
écoutez au nom du gouvernement français
je démens de la manière la plus
catégorique que quelques rançon que ce
soit et été versée cela est contraire à
notre à nos principes et à notre
politique maintes fois réaffirmée et
ceux qui ont cru naïvement à
l'efficacité de ce procédé ont échoué en
faire
enfin il est bien évident que nous
n'avons eu aucun contact avec les
ravisseurs
s'agissant des ventes d'armes à l'iran
je suis mandaté par le gouvernement pour
démentir de la manière la plus
catégorique que depuis que nous assumons
la responsabilité du pouvoir
il y est eu la moindre exportations de
matériel militaire vers l'iran